foreign
two last little little quotes from this
again this is the op-ed published in
nature human behavior this week
explaining why science is off
that's not their understanding of what
they've done but uh gender identity an
individual's conception of self as being
a man woman masculine feminine
non-binary ambivalent Etc based in part
on physical psychological and social
factors
oh wait that was a definition that
wasn't a complete sentence so that's why
that read that way it is the internal
experience of a gender role there was a
broad range of range of gender
identities including but not limited too
you ready oh yeah okay there's a broad
range of gender identities including but
unlimited too transgender gender queer
gender fluid non-binary gender variant
genderless agender non-gender by gender
trans man trans woman transmasculine
trans feminine and cisgender
and then then two paragraphs down they
say researchers are encouraged to
promote equality between men and women
and their academic research which by
Nature should be grounded on the
recognition of Merit competences and
creativity regardless of any other
personal attributes orientation
well if they're going to divide the
spoils between men and women where does
that leave the gender fluid people I
don't know or the agenda or the
non-gender or the genderqueer or the
the envies
oh my I mean I'm actually glad that's in
there because
the language beforehand if you don't
know how science is supposed to work and
what they're actually saying and what it
would do to actual science right it's a
little subtle it's a little so we're
here if we're trying to reveal it as not
being subtle but yeah you could have a
am I misreading this uh response until
you get to that business and then it's
like oh I get it this is just some sort
of ideological polemic and uh this is no
longer a scientific journal get it you
captured it yep um enjoy it
enjoy it until you wear it to the ground
which you're in the process of doing
yeah exactly yeah let's let's take let's
take the functional things in society
take them over
and Destroy them
and then look for more things to take
over and Destroy but you know what
they're not gonna last forever there's
not an infinite amount of successful
actual systems because you're destroying
them too fast okay but then next next
phase
we are about to discover what you and I
already suspect which is that our field
doesn't exist in any meaningful form
anymore because our field being broadly
evolutionary biology is evolutionary
biology and biology human behavior no
human behavior
R is our field
going to come together and say that
nature human behavior is effectively no
longer a scientific journal and should
not be taken seriously because that's
the obviously right response here or are
they going to continue to publish there
and put it on their CVS proudly and I
don't know what the name for this
behavior is the cowardice that causes
you when somebody is powerful not to
call out their destruction of things
that you consider to be fundamental but
if that is what happens here then it
will effectively tell you you can safely
ignore this field because
yep they did us a favor they published
that editorial in a place that we can
read it but where else do these beliefs
have an important editorial role what
are they adjusting about what it is
you're reading in the journals right
well and that's why you know that's why
I organize this the way I did we started
with the internet Rando and we went to
the Scientific American you know the
magazine that is supposed to be
disseminating a a comprehensible version
of new science to people who are smart
but not scientifically
uh
precise and I can't think of the right
word but like not professionals within
science yeah and then the scientific
journals and it's like I said like I
said up front it the language sounds
different you know these guys sign uh
nature of human behavior is not talking
about morphological Freedom yet
but it's all the same it's certainly
opening the door to it it's all the same
stuff it's it's utterly insane across
the board and the fact is that you don't
have to squint very hard to say actually
um internet Rando and the most previous
prestigious scientific journal are
sounding a lot like one another here and
um they're they're all wrong they're
just they're they're pretending that
reality doesn't exist and imagining that
by doing so they will change what
reality is and that's it doesn't work
that way it doesn't work that way yeah
another way to say it is that you have a
um
an ideology
asserting its conclusions its baseless
conclusions and it is doing it now it is
so powerful that it is doing it at every
level so that if you are an internet
Rando yourself you can go
you know Tweet back at it on Twitter and
if you're a you know a uh an academic
you know who views yourself as an
important part of
uh what makes Humanity civilized then
you get your version of it dressed up in
the proper language for that but the
point is there's no difference in the uh
rigor of that essay versus the internet
Rando those are they're exactly
equivalent in terms of their utility as
uh you know their insightfulness it's
not Insight it's the assertion of an
ideological position dressed up as the
conclusion of sober people thinking
carefully about issues that's exactly
right
that's exactly right
so that's reality for you
[Music]